we've got four numbers here what I want
to do is try to round each of these to
the nearest 10 and to the nearest
hundred so I encourage you to pause the
video and try that right now so let's
make two columns let's make one first
for the nearest nearest ten and then
make another column for the nearest 100
nearest 100 and let's start with 154 so
154 what is the multiple of 10 above 154
well it's 160 and the multiple of 10
below 154 is 150 so we're going to round
up to 160 or down to 150 well when we
rounding to the nearest 10 we need to
look at the ones place one place to the
right of the place that we're rounding
so we look at this 4 in the ones place
since 4 is less than 5 we round down to
150 now let's think about that same
number rounding to the nearest hundred
so 154 to the nearest hundred so now we
need to think about if we were to round
up what's the multiple of a hundred
above 150 for 160 isn't a multiple of
100 the multiple of 100 above 154 is 200
what's the multiple of 100 below 154
well that's going to be 100 so if we're
going to round to the nearest hundred so
we look at the hundreds place
we'll look one place to the right of
that which is the tens place if that
place is five or greater we round up if
it's less than 5 we round down well this
is clearly 5 or greater so we round up
so this is interesting when we rounded
to the nearest 10 since we had a 4 in
the ones place we rounded down but when
we rounded to the nearest hundreds since
we had a 5 in the tens place we rounded
up to 200 let's do some more of these
this is fun so four thousand six hundred
and seventy-four four thousand six
hundred and seventy for the multiple of
10 above that is four thousand six
hundred and eighty the multiple of 10
below that four thousand six hundred and
seventy remember
we're concerned only with the multiple
of 10 so do we round up or down well
we're thinking about rounding the tens
place so it's see that's why it's either
going to be an 8 if we round up or 7 if
we round down to figure that out we look
at the ones place the ones place is 5 or
greater we round up if it's less than 5
we round down it's once again less than
5 so we round down to 4670 now let's
round the same number to the nearest
hundred four thousand six hundred and
seventy four what's the multiple of 100
below this well the multiple 100 below
this is four thousand six hundred the
multiple of 100 above this is four
thousand seven hundred if we're trying
to think about rounding to the nearest
hundred we want to look at the tens
place the tens place is five or greater
so we round up to four thousand seven
hundred now let's tackle nine thousand
nine hundred and ninety five and once
again always try to pause these if you
haven't done so already to try to do
this on your own so nine thousand nine
hundred and ninety five what is the
multiple of 10 below this well the
multiple ten below this is nine thousand
nine hundred and ninety and what's the
multiple of 10 above this well if you
increase this by ten you actually get to
ten thousand you get to ten thousand so
you might say hey well isn't this a
multiple of 100 and actually this is a
multiple of a thousand it's also a
multiple of ten thousand it's all of
those but the multiple of ten right
above nine thousand nine hundred ninety
five is ten thousand you just have to
add a little bit to this to get to ten
thousand or the multiple of 10 below it
is clearly nine thousand nine hundred
ninety 10 more than that gets you to ten
thousand so how do we round this well
once again if we're rounding to the
nearest ten we want to look at the ones
place the ones place is five or greater
so we round up to ten thousand
now let's round to the nearest hundreds
we should be getting used to this now to
the nearest hundreds what is the
hundreds below this well it's nine
thousand nine hundred nine thousand nine
hundred what is a hundred above this and
next multiple of 100 above this well if
you add 100 to 9900 you once again get
10,000 so how do we decide whether to
round up or down well we don't look at
the ones place anymore we're now
rounding to the nearest hundred so we
want to round to the nearest hundred to
do that we look one place to the right
which is the tens place if this is five
or greater we round up if it's less than
5 we round down it is 5 or greater so
once again we round up to 10,000 now we
have one more eight thousand three
hundred and forty six so eight thousand
eight thousand three hundred and forty
six the tens place or that the multiple
of 10 below it is eight thousand three
hundred and forty multiple of 10 above
that is eight thousand three hundred and
fifty if we're going to round to the
nearest ten we need to look at the ones
place the ones place is five or greater
so we round up now let's round to the
nearest hundred eight thousand three
hundred and forty six the hundreds
multiple of 100 above this is eight
thousand four hundred the multiple of
100 below this is eight thousand three
hundred notice we're rounding to the
nearest hundreds if we were to round up
the hundreds place becomes a four if we
round down the hundreds place stays of
three but it's followed by zeros if we
want to round to the nearest hundreds we
need to look at the tens place the tens
place here is less than 5 so we round
down to eight thousand three hundred
notice again when we rounded to the
nearest tens we rounded up to eight
thousand three hundred fifty when we
round to the nearest hundreds we rounded
down to eight thousand three hundred